What if your reality was nothing more than a complex computer simulation?
How would you know what kind of technology could make the simulation possible?
And how could you break out of the Matrix?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if you were living in a simulation.
This is what the very first computer games looked like and this is what they've
come to look like after some 50 years of technological progress today,
it only takes a virtual reality headset to jump into a computer simulated realm.
Our future computers may be able to generate entire simulated universes,
and if we humans,
we're able to simulate complex realities.
How can we ever be sure that our own world wasn't just a computer simulation
designed by another more advanced civilization?
Everything and the world we live in seems to be based on mathematical laws.
Even our genetic code has a mathematical model.
Just like if someone had programmed our reality with a computer code,
see where I'm going with this?
We may be living in a giant video game without realizing it,
but who designed this matrix and advanced alien civilization?
Maybe not aliens,
but a future iteration of humanity simulating the lives of their ancestors,
which would make you a living memory of someone else's.
Great,
great,
great grandmother.
This future humanity would require extremely powerful supercomputers to run the
simulation down to the subatomic level,
much more powerful than the most advanced super computer we could imagine.
If we ever got to this level of technological advancement and started running
computer simulations of our own,
that would be very strong evidence that our reality was also simulated a
simulation creating their own simulation.
Chances are our creators would turn out to be someone else's simulation
in the many,
many simulations from the original reality on down.
Each subsequent simulation would turn out less and less advanced.
They just wouldn't be able to match their creators in advancing their
technologies.
If your life was a simulation,
you would know just like there's no proof that you're not living in a
simulation,
but you could try looking for the glitches.
If our world was some computer code,
it could have software bugs every now and then when our simulators decided to
roll it,
update,
something could slip sideways.
It could be a glitch,
like meeting your doppelganger.
Someone who looks like you put isn't related to you.
It might just be a mix and character appearance preferences.
If we ever found out that we were a program on someone's hard drive,
it could be because that's someone wanted us to,
in that case,
escaping the simulation would be well simulated.
We just end up on another level of the Matrix.
Maybe discovering the identity of our creators would make them reboot the
system.
A big control,
alt delete for the entire universe.
Reality may not be a quantum computer simulation,
but if it is,
would it change anything in your day to day life?
Maybe one day we'll discover that we live in the multiverse,
but that's a story for another.
What if.